direction présents le festival de cannes
ou dans le cadre de la quinzaine des
réalisateurs se perpétue la tradition
des films politiques celui dont nous
allons vous parler est consacré à la vie
du leader africain patrice lumumba
cet homme qui était surnommé le père de
l'indépendance congolaise a été
assassiné en 1961 dans des conditions
qui restent toujours floues le
réalisateur haïtien de ce film en a fait
un véritable thriller que nous
présentent tout de suite antoine cormery
et patrick becker qui se souvient de
patrice lumumba qui se souvient de la
fin tragique de celui qui fut l'éphémère
premier ministre du congo belge devenu
indépendant c'était en 1960 au coeur de
l'afrique en pleine guerre froide en
pleine décolonisation
e
le monde a surtout marqué la génération
de 68 puisque c'est les premières démos
manifestations estudiantines s'est fait
à l'annoncé de l'assassinât de lumumba
il y a eu des émeutes un peu partout
dans les grandes capitales européennes
et c'était vraiment comme je vous dise
cette époque où les gens étaient pleins
d'idéalisme ils pensaient qu'ils
allaient changer le monde et en afrique
c'était la même chose mais la
décolonisation tourne au bain de sang
patrick lumumba qui rêvent d'un congo
libre et unie va se retrouver le jouet
de forces qui le dépassent dans un pays
dont les richesses minières notamment
attise toutes les convoitises pour faire
appel à l'audi est que donner le
meilleur co si on doit engager une
opération militaire vous pensez pas que
les riches et russes ont dit déjà que
j'ai si le jouet des communistes vous
voulez me faire assassiner par la cia
l'injustice est tellement grande par
rapport au continent noir par rapport à
l'afrique par rapport à la maigritude
par rapport à la minorité visible si
j'ose dire qu on a tous un venin qu'on a
envie de cracher sas sas et louvre
qu'est ce que tu veux gros jeu dira le
président a ordonné de vient d'arrêter
je voulais tant plaisir
la trahison de mobutu les intrigues de
la cia donne à raoul peck matière à un
thriller politique dans la lignée de
ceux de costa gavras
présenté à la quinzaine des réalisateurs
le seul film sur l'afrique cette année à
cannes nat